C'est qui lui ?
L'évadé perpétuel.
Vidocq, monsieur.
On vous accuse d'un meurtre.
Cette fois, c'est la guillotine.
Et moi je vous dis que je n'ai rien fait.
Je connais les coupables, libérez-moi et je vous les ramène.
Il faut lutter contre les hommes comme ça.
Vous devez connaître leurs manies, leurs habitudes, leur monde.
Je vois bien que vous êtiez l'un d'eux...
Non je ne suis pas l'un d'eux.
Vous avez besoin de résultats, je vais vous les fournir.
Mais à quel prix ?
Ma lettre de grâce.
Ah bon ? Rien que ça.
Un voleur reste un voleur.
Mais des résultats restent des résultats.
Tu sais, je me moque de  savoir qui tu es.
Toi peut-être, mais d'autres pas.
Je peux rendre des services
en payant une lettre de grâce par exemple....
J'aime profondément
votre conception de la France, Vidocq
Qu'est ce que tu feras, toi,
quand tout ça sera terminé ?
J'ai fait de nous les Empereurs de Paris.
Il n'y aura jamais qu'un seul Empereur.
Servir votre pays, ou bien rester dans
l'ombre et la médiocrité.
Il va vous falloir choisir, Vidocq.